do you have a concept in your head that
you've had for years
that you just can't figure out we've had
an idea for a long time about like
it's like aliens come to earth and
they're like
we're gonna test you and the planet will
live or die based on how you deal with
this test and we're going to pick one
human representative to be the vanguard
of
all of humanity and i get picked as that
person
um and so i had that and that's the idea
but and that's a great premise that's a
good premise
but that's you know around eight years
later that's still all we have
and how often do you and your writing
partner pull that out of this uh
virtual folder and say look
there's that idea again sometimes
someone else will pitch us something and
they'll be like oh i have an idea for
this alien thing or something and we
were like oh maybe actually like we've
had this idea maybe they can kind of
link them together
and that's what i think probably will
happen one day with that idea
is someone else will come to us with
another idea that that idea kind of
supports more than anything you know but
some movies are like scams
where like it's like buying blueprints
to a house that looked
nice but then when you try to actually
build the house it doesn't stand up
properly you know what i mean like
right that is a thing that that happens
with
films and and i recognize it sometimes
where i will see a movie and be like oh
they they lied to like whoever wrote and
directed this movie lied and like
this this is not like they made it seem
like they were
selling the studio an actual functional
film but they did not they
they sold them like the schematics of a
movie that when
built does not hold up to stress testing
have you actually gone in
and tried to help out a movie i will
only say this because it was reported
and i'm going to tread lightly because
i'm close with many of the people
involved but i i did that on the dr
doolittle film a little bit is that a
fun experience in the sense that you
you don't have anything emotionally
invested in the film i mean i would
imagine that's pretty heady stuff
yeah i mean it's a very like it's a
cushy on the grand scale of positions to
be in as a writer it's it's a cushy
position to be
in stakes are low for you
personally in that role um which is nice
uh but it's also like you want to help i
mean and that's what's also you know
like
i i i like movies and i like also i
i like the actors in that movie and i
want i don't want anyone to not be happy
with the movie and
universal who made that movie like has
been very supportive of me and my career
and made a lot of our movies and
i like the people who worked there so i
genuinely want to make things better if
i can